in this video we'll talk about mast
cells which are involved in the allergic
response mast cells were discovered by
Paul elrich in 1877. mast cells are
residing underneath the connective
tissue also they contain granules which
are enriched in histamine and heparin
which are important modulators in
immunity
now where can muscles be found they can
be found in many epithelial layers they
can be found in connective tissues as
well mucosal epithelial tissues skin
especially they are found in genital
urinary tract and respiratory epithelium
mass cells are not circulating in the
bloodstream like neutrophils
in fact comprises only one percent of
the circulating leukocytes
mast cells are born from the bone marrow
from the myeloid progenitor cell but in
the bloodstream they are initially in an
immature State eventually they move from
the bloodstream to the tissue space
where their differentiation can take
place and they become mature mast cells
muscles are highly associated with
allergic responses mast cell has
specific receptors known as FC receptors
which can bind to
ige antibodies
so whenever there is an allergen
mediated exposure mast cells get
sensitized and they degranulate and in
these granules there are several
allergic mediators
so there are many physiological outcomes
of Mast Cell regranulation like
bronchoconstriction increased glandular
secretion smooth muscle country
constriction and vasodilation
muscles and basophils are kind of
similar but they have distinct
differences as well so first of all
their nucleus are very different mast
cell has a roundish shaped nucleus
whereas the basophil has bilobed nucleus
but both of them has the common surface
marker cd34
mast cells are generated from the bone
marrow but when they are secreted they
are kind of immature but basophils are
secreted kind of in a maturation state
muscle granule composition is pretty
diverse it has serine proteases like
tryptase
Etc it has histamine serotonin which are
mediators of allergic responses it has
many proteoglycans like Heparin which is
an anticoagulant
it has several lysosomal enzymes like
beta hydroximinase beta gluconeidase and
many others
mast cell are capable of secreting bunch
of cytokines some of the most important
cytokines are tnf alpha interleukin-4
then they also secrete chemokines such
as eosinophil chemotactic Factor so they
can also attract eosinophils by these
chemokines
since muscle take part in allergic
response it's important to note that
muscle is capable of secreting lipid
mediators generally the ecosanoids such
as prostaglandins thromboxins all of
that Bim are kind of associated with the
inflammatory response
now muscle can eliminate bacteria as
well as parasitic infection muscle has
the capability to interact with
dendritic Cell B cell T cells Etc by
secreting cytokine they can modulate the
function of these cells
mast cells has pattern recognition
receptors such as tlr2 which recognize
broadly the gram-positive bacteria and
few selective gram-negative bacteria
and also tlr4 which are generally
sensitive to the gram-negative bacteria
so Marcel can recognize them and take
precautions to eliminate them
other than these functions mast cells
are involved in enhanced
angiogenesis that means creation of new
blood vessels
mast cells secretes a bunch of
angiogenic factors such as vegf bjfgf
TGF beta tnf Alpha and interleukin-8 all
of these promote angiogenesis
muscle is associated with many disease
and these diseases are broadly
classified as intrinsic factors that
modulate the disease and extrinsic
Factor so extrinsic Factor mediated
diseases involve allergy so you all
already know that allergy is due to some
kind of external allergy in pollen grain
Etc
also there could be NFI Lexis
now intrinsic factors that lead to
muscle mediated diseases involve
systemic mastocytosis and cutaneous
mastocytosis also there is Mast Cell
Activation Syndrome
now cutaneous mastocytosis is a kind of
disease which is characterized by
several bumps in the skin which can be
very similar to rashes and could be
painful sometimes they are mistaken as
blisters
there could be systemic mastocytosis
which also involves several rashes
stress joint pain overall body pain and
kind of like fatigue
anyway
this video tells you about the origin of
muscles how they do their job and how
they are associated with several
diseases like these ones so I hope this
video was informative if you like this
video give it a good Thumbs Up Get notes
and flash cards in my Facebook Channel
and also in Instagram if you want to
support our YouTube channel you can
click on the super thanks option just
below the video and you can pay via
paytm UPI PayPal
Etc see you in next video